>> Sean: IF YOU WANT TO HANG
OUT, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
TONIGHT, WE ARE TRACKING
MULTIPLE VERY BIG BREAKING
DEVELOPING STORIES.
COMING UP, THE NEW DETAILS
SURROUNDING THE LINCOLN PROJECT
SCANDAL.
THIS STORY KEEPS GETTING WORSE
AND WORSE BY THE DAY.
A SMOKING GUN EMAIL HAS JUST
REVEALED SHOWING JAMES COMEY NEW
HILLARY CLINTON’S DIRTY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION DOSSIER WAS
UNVERIFIED, YET HE SIGNED THREE
PHIS APPLICATIONS, NOW WE ARE
CERTAIN HE SIGNED UP ON KNOWING
IT NOT VERIFIABLE.
JOHN DURHAM, WHERE ARE YOU?
ALSO TONIGHT, NEW YORK
GOVERNOR CUOMO NOW FACING
WIDESPREAD CONDEMNATION FROM
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE, BUT
WILL HE BE HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR
HIS COVID NURSING HOME DEATH
COVER-UP?
WE HAVE A FULL REPORT STRAIGHT
AHEAD AND ALSO LATER, VERY
LATEST RUN DOWN ON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION’S RADICAL FAR
LEFT AGENDA INCLUDING NOW COMING
FOR YOUR SECOND AMENDMENT AS WE
WARNED YOU.
DONALD TRUMP JR. WILL BE JOINING
US TONIGHT, DAN BONGINO WILL BE
HERE BUT FIRST, THIS WEEKEND IN
WHAT COULD BE THE LEAST SHOCKING
DEVELOPMENT WE TOLD YOU ALL LAST
WEEK WAS PREDETERMINED THE
OUTCOME, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP WAS OFFICIALLY
ACQUITTED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE SENATE HAVING TRIED
DONALD JOHN TRUMP UP ON ARTICLE
OF IMPEACHMENT EXHIBITED AGAINST
HIM BY THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, TWO-THIRDS OF
THE SENATORS PRESENT NOT HAVING
FOUND HIM GUILTY OF THE CHARGE
CONTAINED THEREIN IS THEREFORE
ORDERED AND ADJUDGED THAT
DONALD J. TRUMP IS HERE BY
ACQUITTED FOR THE CHARGE IN SAID
ARTICLE.
>> Sean: LET’S MAKE ONE THING
CLEAR, OTHER REPUBLICANS HAVE
TURNED THEIR BACKS ON THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OUR WAY OUT OF TOUCH
WITH THE BASE OF THEIR OWN PARTY
PARTY.
RECORD 75 MILLION AMERICANS
TURNED OUT FOR DONALD TRUMP IN
NOVEMBER AND THEY SUPPORTED HIM
TO THIS VERY DAY.
TAKE A LOOK RIGHT THERE, SEE
THAT VIDEO, SEE WHAT’S ON YOUR
SCREEN?
A FEW HOURS AGO, SPONTANEOUSLY,
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN
PALM BEACH LINED UP IN SUPPORT
OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT AS HIS
MOTORCADE TRAVELED THROUGH
FLORIDA.
I HAVE A QUESTION,
MITCH McCONNELL, JOHN THUNE,
HOW COME YOU NEVER HAD THIS KIND
OF ENTHUSIASM AT ANY OF YOUR
EVENTS?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> USA!
USA!
>> Sean: VOTERS IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE SMART, NOT STUPID.
WE CAN SEE THE SNAP IMPEACHMENT
WAS NOTHING BUT POLITICAL
THEATER, NO DUE PROCESS, NO
EVIDENCE, NO DEFENSE, NONE OF IT
AND NOW FINDING OUT IT WAS ALL
PREPLANNED AHEAD OF TIME AND
ANOTHER NEEDLESS SMEAR THAT
ACCOMPLISHED NOTHING.
IT’S BEEN FIVE YEARS OF THIS.
THEY’VE ALSO HAD IT WITH
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATIC SWAMP
CREATURES, AND THIS IS THE
QUESTION THE REPUBLICANS ARE NOW
GOING TO HAVE TO ASK THEMSELVES
TONIGHT.
WHERE WAS JOHN THUNE AND
MITCH McCONNELL FIGHTING
AGAINST THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER AND CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
OUR HISTORY WITH OPERATION
CROSSFIRE HURRICANE?
THEY WERE MISSING IN ACTION.
WHERE IS THE SANCTIMONIOUS
MITCH McCONNELL, JOHN THUNE
DEMANDING THAT KAMALA HARRIS,
CHUCK SCHUMER, NANCY PELOSI,
MAXINE WATERS, WHEN IS HE GOING
TO GIVE A SPEECH ON THE SENATE
FLOOR AND HOLD THOSE DEMOCRATS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR INCITEMENT
OF INSURRECTION AND THEY ARE
INSURRECTION LIKE LANGUAGE?
THE TIME IS NOW COMING FOR NO
LEADERSHIP IN THE U.S. SENATE.
WILL BE DEALING WITH THAT.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE IN THE
DAYS TO COME.
THERE IS IMPORTANT WORK THAT
DOES NEED TO BE DONE.
IT’S URGENT.
THIS WAS ALL PUT ON HOLD BECAUSE
OF THIS POLITICAL LATEST SHOW
TRIAL IN THIS CASE FIRST AND
FOREMOST, WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
6TH OF JANUARY CAN NEVER HAPPEN
AGAIN.
OUR CAPITAL WAS ATTACKED,
ELECTED LAWMAKERS IN BOTH
PARTIES WILL PUT IN HARM’S WAY.
THAT CAN’T EVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
ALL THOSE THAT BROKE THE LAW
MUST BE HELD RESPONSIBLE AND WE
NEED A FULL INVESTIGATION INTO
WHAT WENT WRONG.
THE SECURITY WAS BREACHED WITHIN
MINUTES, THE CAPITOL POLICE WERE
OVERWHELMED PRIOR TO THE BREACH,
THE CAPITAL POLICE CHIEF
REQUESTED THE NATIONAL GUARD AND
THEIR ASSISTANCE SIX SEPARATE
TIMES, EVERY PLEA OF HIS WAS
REJECTED.
THE PRESIDENT WAS VERY VOCAL
ABOUT OFFERING HIS SECURITY
ASSISTANCE LEADING UP TO JANUARY
10,000 NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS TO
BE ON STANDBY AND BE READY, BUT
THEY WERE NOT CALLED ON UNTIL IT
WAS TOO LATE.
WHY DID THIS HAPPEN?
THEY KNEW A MASSIVE CROWD OF
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE,
THEY KNEW DAYS BEFORE THEY WERE
DESCENDING ON WASHINGTON, THEY
KNEW THE NIGHT BEFORE THEY WERE
THERE, THEY KNEW THIS WAS AN
IMPORTANT DAY IN THE HALLS OF
CONGRESS, THEY KNEW THE
VICE PRESIDENT AND ALL OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS WOULD BE
INSIDE THE CAPITOL BUILDING.
THEY KNEW THAT VIOLENT
INDIVIDUALS WE NOW KNOW WERE
PLOTTING AND PLANNING AND
SCHEMING.
THEY WERE WARNED THE FBI KNEW
ABOUT THE PLOTS, THE PLANNING,
THE SCHEMING, AS DID OTHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
EVEN CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
CAUSEY OFOCASIO-CORTEZ CLAIMED S
WARNED OF THE ATTACK AHEAD OF
TIME.
THE PERSON ULTIMATELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR SECURITY IN THE
HOUSE WOULD BE NANCY PELOSI.
THE SERGEANT OF ARMS ANSWERS TO
HER BUT INSTEAD OF GETTING TO
THE BOTTOM OF THIS MASSIVE
SECURITY FAILURE, NO, THE
SPEAKER JUST RUSHED THROUGH YET
ANOTHER SNAP IMPEACHMENT, NO DUE
PROCESS, NO PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE, NO DEFENSE, HAVING A
NO FAX AND NO INVESTIGATION AND
RECENTLY, SHE DIDN’T EVEN WANT
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS
MASSIVE POST-9/11 SECURITY
FAILURE SHE CALLED A WASTE OF
TIME.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AS FAR AS THE IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL IS CONCERNED,
SENATOR GRAHAM SAID THAT IF THE
DEMOCRATS CALL ANY WITNESS THAT
THEY WILL BE PREPARED TO CALL IN
THE FBI AND "TELL US ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO PLANNED THIS ATTACK
AND WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
SECURITY FOOTPRINT AT THE
CAPITOL.
WHAT’S YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> YOUR QUESTION IS A WASTE OF
TIME.
>> Sean: PROTECTING OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND PROTECTING
ELECTED OFFICIALS FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE IS NOT A
WASTE OF TIME AND NOW THAT THE
IMPEACHMENT CHARADE IS OVER
HAVING NEVER INVESTIGATED A
THING, PELOSI IS NOW FINALLY
ORDERING A FULL-SCALE
INVESTIGATION.
I’M SURE IT WILL FOCUS ONLY ON
DONALD TRUMP.
THE REASON FOR THE DELAY IS
OBVIOUS, NANCY PELOSI KNEW ANY
SERIOUS INVESTIGATION WOULD
CLEAR PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THERE
WAS A MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE THAT
ALL OF THIS WAS PREPLANNED AND
THE MULTIPLE SERIOUS WARNINGS
WERE MISSED OR IGNORED, IT CAN’T
HAPPEN.
CLEARLY JANUARY 6TH, THOSE
REMARKS COULD NOT HAVE INCITED
INSURRECTION IF THE ATTACK WAS
ORGANIZED WELL BEFORE JANUARY
JANUARY 6TH, WHICH WE NOW KNOW
FROM COURT DOCUMENTS, THE FBI,
AND SO MANY OTHERS.
SO THE YOU POLITICAL SCHIFF SHOW
CHARADE IS OUT OF THE WAY,
PELOSI CAN FINALLY GET ON WITH
THE BUSINESS OF PROTECTING EVERY
ELECTED OFFICIAL AND OUR HOUSE,
THE PEOPLE’S HOUSE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THIS IS SWAMP
SEWER POLITICS AT ITS WORST.
EVEN REPUBLICANS LIKE
MITCH McCONNELL AND OTHERS,
MEANWHILE THIS FAILS SNAPPED
IMPEACHMENT ALSO SETS A
DANGEROUS NEW PRECEDENT.
DONALD TRUMP CAN BE IMPEACHED
FOR POLITICAL SPEECH WHERE HE
URGED SUPPORTERS TO FIGHT LIKE.
THERE’S A TEN MINUTE MONTAGE
DURING THE TRIAL, DAVID SCHOEN
WILL SHOW US, AIRED OUT FOR ALL
OF US TO SEE IN MANY OF YOU WILL
NOW PEACEFULLY SO YOUR VOICES
WILL BE HEARD
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
EXPLAINED, NOW PANDORA’S BOX HAS
BEEN WIDE OPEN.
LET’S SEE IF REPUBLICANS WILL
HOLD DEMOCRATS TO THE NEW
STANDARD.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE’VE OPENED PANDORA’S BOX TO
FUTURE PRESIDENTS AND IF YOU USE
THIS MODEL, I DON’T KNOW HOW
KAMALA HARRIS DOESN’T GET
IMPEACHED IF THE REPUBLICANS
TAKE OVER THE HOUSE BECAUSE HE
ACTUALLY BAILED OUT RIOTERS AND
THEY WENT BACK TO THE STREETS
AND BROKE SOMEBODY’S HEAD OPEN
SO WE’VE OPENED PANDORA’S BOX
AND I’M SAD FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: SO ARE THEY NOW GOING
TO USE THE SAME STANDARD THAT
WAS USED AGAINST DONALD TRUMP ON
INCITING INSURRECTION?
THERE’S A LONG AND GROWING LIST
OF DEMOCRATS WHO SHOULD NOW
QUALIFY FOR IMPEACHMENT AND
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL, YOU CAN START
WITH KAMALA HARRIS,
CHUCK SCHUMER, JOE BIDEN AND
WORK YOUR WAY THROUGH THE LIST
BUT OF COURSE SWAMP CREATURES,
THE MEDIA MOB WILL LIKELY NEVER
HOLD DEMOCRATS TO THE SAME
STANDARD THEY HELD DONALD TRUMP
TWO.
PRETTY MUCH THE HISTORY OF THE
LAST FIVE YEARS.
LAST WEEK, TOO BUSY BREATHLESSLY
CHEERING ON HOUSE IMPEACHMENT
MANAGERS AND IT WAS ALL
NAUSEATING AND NOBODY IN THIS
COUNTRY IS BETTER OFF BECAUSE OF
IT.
MEANWHILE, THE MEDIA HAD NO
SHORTAGE OF COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT’S LEGAL TEAM AND THEY
DELIVERED AN EPIC BEAT DOWN WITH
AN EXCELLENT DEFENSE THAT WAS
PUT TOGETHER IN ABOUT EIGHT DAYS
DAYS.
OVER THE WEEKEND, ONE OF THE
PRESIDENT’S ATTORNEYS DEALING
THE CBS ANCHOR VOICED HIS
FRUSTRATION WITH THE MOB DURING
INTERVIEW ON THAT NETWORK.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE MEDIA HAS TO START
TELLING THE RIGHT STORY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THE MEDIA IS TRYING TO DIVIDE
THIS COUNTRY.
YOU ARE BLOODTHIRSTY FOR RATINGS
AND AS SUCH, YOU’RE ASKING
QUESTIONS NOW THAT ARE ALREADY
SET UP WITH THE FACT PATTERN.
THAT’S THE PROBLEM, THE MEDIA
HAS TO START LIVING BY THE TRUTH
TRUTH.
AND NOT TRY TO CREATE A
NARRATIVE.
>> MICHAEL VANDERVEEN, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US.
I DO APPRECIATE.
OKAY.
I SEE YOU TAKING OFF YOUR
MICROPHONE NOW.
>> Sean: HE DID.
IMAGINE HAVING ALMOST EVERY NEWS
OUTLET IN THE COUNTRY ROOTING
AGAINST YOU, EVERY TV SHOW,
EVERY ARTICLE, EVERY HEADLINE,
EVERY PUNDIT EVERY SECOND, EVERY
MINUTE, EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY.
THAT’S WHAT THIS COUNTRY HAS
LIVED THROUGH, DONALD TRUMP AT
HIS FAMILY HAVE LIVED THROUGH
THE LAST FIVE YEARS AND THAT IS
WHAT THE PRESIDENT’S LAWYERS
FACED OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS
AND THIS IS WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AGAIN FACED WERE FIVE YEARS.
JOURNALISM IN THIS COUNTRY IS
DEAD AND BURIED.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF AN